I have a pie yeah do you wanna hold it
do you know what it's made of
rebel is it brat kaupapa is copper
magnetic oh I'm gonna go no I didn't
think it was okay I'm gonna go yes well
why don't we check this is a magnet and
I'd like you to use it to test whether
the copper is is magnetic no I want you
to be a hundred percent sure here what
do you think no it's not magnetic
okay is there anything in there no what
do you seeing then that's nothing
so why don't we drop something through
it just make sure it's empty right yeah
this is not a magnet so this isn't a
magnet but let's see what happens when
we drop it through whew that was a dull
experiment one that yeah yeah okay so
what's going to happen if we drop this
magnet down the pipe foolproof let's do
it
three two one
that was good let's welcome
- it longer what's slowing the magnet
down it's probably magnetic poles or
something other name north-south trying
to do the priority the north in the
South Poles well it doesn't sink but
then it's on magnetics I shouldn't do
anything right you guys so that like
that is slightly magnetic on the inside
somehow it's gonna be my mate inside
there's no something does it like on a
suits I think it's the powers of the
universe I don't know I don't know who
is doing it well this is what's exciting
is only a few blocks from here was the
lab of a guy called ferry dam in October
1831 he built world's first election Oh
to hear magnet which you push and pull
you know coil generate account so that's
the actual yeah world's first night
regeneration is a permanent magnet and
the most permanent magnet yup it was
Faraday who realized that it's a
changing magnetic field that actually
can generate electric current so as the
magnet is falling through the pipe it's
creating a changing magnetic field that
generates little electric currents so
called eddy currents in the pipe and
they create an opposing magnetic force
on the magnet slowing it down so it
actually turns the pipe into an
electromagnet IC which pushes the magnet
up and this is what's known as
electromagnetic induction
so causes my led to light up there but
it's important that you move the magnet
quickly because if you move it too
slowly the magnetic field is not
changing fast enough to generate enough
voltage to light this LED this is
actually the way all electricity is
generated is it yeah you move a magnet
near a conductor and it creates electric
current but where is this electrical
energy coming from you can't get energy
for nothing well Faraday realized that
there must be a force pushing back on
the magnet it's the same force that
slows this magnet down as it falls
through the pipe
so there's actually energy being
converted from gravitational potential
energy into electrical energy and
eventually the heat so this pipe is
warming up by taking some of the energy
out of the falling magnet that me good
or what oh it's very good
grace and these currents coming around
this way will induce a magnetic field
pushing in the opposite direction
we took a great thing you're fine
minutes right okay
pop it up there and then a nice little
Wyatt our best fan the best size